the opening scene features 12-year-old
boy named Dre Parker who lives with his
widowed mother named Sherry in Detroit
one day the two have to leave their
Hometown and relocate to beay Jang as
Sher gets a job transfer at a car
factory Dre doesn't seem as excited as
his mother because he doesn't think the
new place will be any better than his
hometown regardless he has no other
choice following this they bid a final
goodbye to their friends and neighbors
before setting off to the airport while
on the flight his mother goes through
some Chinese language tutorials and
encourages Dre to do the same however
the boy doesn't show any interest in it
upon Landing in Beijing they are
received by a local guide who directs
them to their new residence Dre finds
the atmosphere in Beijing to be
completely different from where he used
to live even his favorite cartoon is
dubbed in Chinese which he doesn't
understand at all thankfully he finds a
neighboring boy named Harry who speaks
English and soon befriends him a short
while later Sherry asks Dre to call a
maintenance man named Mr Han because the
hot waterfall closet isn't working and
Lincoln Park's DJ can certainly help
with that obeying his mother's order the
boy goes looking for Mr Han he tries
asking the local people but nobody seems
to understand English despite this he
somehow manages to locate Mr Han who is
currently having his lunch Dre complains
about the faucet but Mr Han ignores him
and continues eating later that day Dre
goes to a nearby park and plays
basketball with Harry and some other
boys in the midst of this he has his
Gaze on a young violinist named ma Ying
who re deprecates his attention Harry
notices this and suggests Dre talk to
her heeding to the advice he confidently
approaches her and tries to strike up a
conversation with his broken Chinese but
much to his surprise the girl responds
in fluent English which makes him happy
because it means he doesn't have to do
any of the work classic American it
doesn't take much time for them to get
along but they are interrupted by a
15-year-old boy named Chang whose family
is close to mayyang he pushes Dre to the
ground and starts beating him up our boy
tries to retaliate but being a Kung Fu
Prodigy Chang easily defeats him soon
after mayying breaks up the fight and
shouts at Chang to leave after this Dre
returns home and quietly heads to his
room hiding himself from his mother the
next day he puts on his mother's makeup
to hide the bruises on his face before
heading to his new school once there he
learns that mayying Chang and his gang
also attend the same school at lunchtime
Shang deliberately bumps into Dre and
slams the food tray all over him but
before they can get into another fight
the principal walks in and handles the
situation in the afternoon Mr Han visits
Dre's apartment to repair the faucet and
finds the boy practicing Kung Fu from
the television all he wants is to learn
to slap like his dad after completing
the maintenance he calls Dre to teach
him how to operate the hot water but
gets ignored thus he throws a toothpaste
cap at Dre accurately hitting him in the
neck and leaving him surprised not long
after Sherry returns home and is very
annoyed with her son's everyday
undisciplined habit of leaving his
clothes on the floor She berates him for
it while Mr Han Eaves drops on their
conversation hoping that he will one day
leave his clothes on her floor the
following day at school Dre hears the
sound of a violin prompting him to sneak
into an auditorium there he finds
mayyang practicing For an upcoming
audition she claims that joining the
academy is very important for her and
her family so she has to give her best
their conversation is suddenly
interrupted when her teacher walks in
prompting Dre to leave as soon as he
walks out he is again confronted by
Chang and his gang they warn him to keep
a distance from mayying or else face the
consequences after school Dre and his
mother are walking back home when they
come across a kung fu school Dre starts
exploring the place but soon spots Chang
practicing in one of the rooms as a
result his excitement Fades away and he
asks his mother to leave the place
immediately worried by a sudden change
in Behavior Sherry asks about the matter
to to which Dre vents his frustration he
claims that he hates this place and
expresses his wish to return back to
Detroit despite feeling bad for her boy
Sherry can do nothing but console him
one day Dre's School arranges a trip to
the Forbidden City although the boy
takes part he refrains from conversing
much with mayyang due to Chang's
constant watchful gaze after the trip
Dre is on his way home when he notices
Chang and his gang gathering on the road
he's about to pass to avoid being seen
he hides behind a car and waits for the
group to leave just then he notices a
bucket of dirty water and a vengeful
idea strikes his mind he throws the
water over Chang and his gang and runs
away enraged the boys chase him through
the streets and eventually Corner him in
a back alley following this the group
starts beating him brutally knocking him
down to the ground but as Chang is about
to deliver a powerful blow Mr Han
suddenly grabs his wrist he pushes him
away and asks him to go home however the
boys are in no mood to comply they
instead launched their attack on Mr Han
starting a fight in response the
middle-aged man Dodges every attack and
makes them hit each other instead he
manages to defeat them without even
launching a single offensive move he
ultimately fends the gang off revealing
himself to be a Kung Fu Master in the
aftermath Mr Han tends to Dre injuries
using the ancient Chinese medicine
methods of fire cupping he also explains
that Shang and his friends are not
inherently bad but have been influenced
by their teacher Master Lee who teaches
his students to be merciless towards
their enemies intrigued Dre asks if he
can teach him Kung Fu Mr Han refuses and
instead takes him to Lee's fighting
dragon Studio to make peace there the
cruel Master harshly rebuffs the peace
offering and challenges Dre to a fight
with Chang not wanting to make the
situation worse Mr Han and Dre decide to
leave but they are stopped by Lee he
threatens them by saying that they won't
be allowed to leave unless one of them
fights at the same time Mr Han notices a
tournament poster and comes up with a
plan He suggests that Dre compete with
Lee's disciple one-on-one in the
upcoming competition he also asks that
Lee's students leave Dre alone to train
until then Lee begrudgingly accepts as
long as the boy shows up at the
tournament on their way back Mr Han
translates the entire conversation to
Dre who is shocked upon learning that he
now has to fight Chang and his entire
gang he points out that the opponents
are all Kung Fu students to which Mr Han
claims that what they are practicing is
nothing but cruelty he then promises to
teach him the real Kung Fu sparking
excitement in the boy Chris Rock better
watch his back the next day Dre returns
home from school and heads straight to
Mr hans's place for their practice
session upon entering he is surprised to
find a car in the living room curious
about it he inquires but Mr Han evades
the question simply stating that there's
no available parking space outside
without further explanation he then then
initiates Dre's Kung Fu training
starting with basic movements like
taking off the jacket throwing it down
picking it up and hanging it Dre asks
numerous questions but Mr Han answers
none of them and just has him focus on
the training as a result Dre continues
to do these movements over and over
again for days disregarding the weather
conditions one day Sherry interrupts the
training to invite Dre and Mr Han to the
Ki Festival happening the same night
there Dre spots mayyang and goes to talk
to her as their conversation unfolds he
invites her to his Kung Fu tournament
and in return she also invites him to
her violin competition after promising
to be there to support each other the
two share a romantic kiss in the next
scene the training continues until Dre
finally gets fed up with the same boring
training set he decides to quit and even
blames Mr Han claiming that he doesn't
understand Kung Fu hearing this Mr Han
finally reveals the true purpose of the
seemingly monotonous exercises to
develop muscle memory while
demonstrating Dre is surprised to find
that he's able to dodge his master's
mock attacks Mr Han conveys that
Serenity and maturity not just punches
and power are the keys to mastering Kung
Fu he also implores that Kung Fu exists
in every aspect of life including
putting on and taking off your jacket
after learning the deeper meaning of
kung fu Dre finally decides to embrace
the practice wholeheartedly one day Mr
Han takes him to a toist temple in the
wuang mountain mountains the place where
he used to practice Kung Fu with his
father there Dre Witnesses exceptional
Kung Fu abilities and techniques
moreover he is particularly amazed to
witness a woman making a cobra reflect
her movements he then expresses his
desire to learn this but Mr Han asserts
that it requires intense Focus which is
almost impossible to do as a beginner
soon they eventually reach the top of
the temple where Dre drinks water from a
special Dragon well after this they
practice some Kung Fu moves for a while
before returning back home starting from
the next day Mr Han escalates the
training to the next level this time
focusing on Dre's concentration
flexibility and fitness after several
weeks of laborious training he grants
the boy a day off during this break Dre
goes to see mayyang and persuades her to
cut school for a day of fun they then
spend a delightful time together
exploring the city and showing off each
other's dancing skills in the midst of
this maying receives an unexpected phone
call from her father informing her that
that her final audition has been
rescheduled and is set to begin in the
next 20 minutes as a result she is
picked up by her parents and driven
towards the audition venue Dre also runs
towards it and manages to get there
before her performance ends keeping his
promise as the audition ends May Ying's
parents notice her signaling to Dre that
she did it however they deem him a bad
influence because he made her nearly
late for her audition due to this they
forbid her from seeing him ever again
heartbroken Dre returns home only to
discover Mr Hans smashing his car in an
inebriated and depressed state when
questioned Mr H tearfully reveals that
today is the day when he lost his wife
and 10-year-old son in a car accident
after having an argument since then he
destroys the car every year on the
anniversary of the accident and spends
the rest of the year fixing it in order
to punish himself in order to comfort
his teacher Dre pulls him out of the car
and encourages him to continue their
training the boy is now even more
determined to train harder to help Mr
Han overcome his trauma the rigorous
training continues and Dre is dedicated
now more than ever as the tournament
nears he excels in every part of the
practice apart from all this Mr Han also
assists Dre in writing and reciting a
note of apology in Chinese to May Ying's
father surprisingly the latter accepts
it and he also allows May Ying to attend
the tournament to support Dre as she had
promised the scene then cuts to the
tournament day and and Dre seems to be
nervous to see the arena full of
audience his confidence further degrades
upon seeing formidable opponents as the
first round begins Dre due to his
underconfidence steps out of the circle
mad causing him to lose a point however
in the subsequent roundout he maintains
his focus and overpowers his first
opponents boosting his confidence from
this point onward he continues to defeat
his opponents one after another
gradually progressing to the semifinals
simultaneously the boys from fighting
dragon also secure victories over their
opponents with Chang emerging Victorious
as the first finalist through aggressive
fights in the semifinals Dre faces leang
one of the students from fighting dragon
before the fight Master Lee instructs
him to break Dre's leg which he doesn't
want to do despite his belief that he
can defeat Dre without resorting to such
tactics Master Lee sternly tells him
that he doesn't want him beaten but
broken as the round begins leang as per
the order plays dirty by delivering a
series of crippling blows to Dre's leg
this causes him to be disqualified
resulting in Dre advancing to the finals
however he is seriously injured and is
rushed to the medical room upon checking
up the doctor declares that it's
impossible for him to continue fighting
meanwhile on the stage Shang waits to
claim the trophy expecting Victory if
Dre doesn't return in a few minutes on
the other hand Dre pleads with Mr Han to
heal his leg via the fire cupping method
the ladder initially hesitates as he
can't see Dre hurt anymore however the
boy manages to convince him saying that
he wants to overcome his fears and prove
himself in front of everyone as a result
Mr Han performs the aid enabling Dre to
return back to the arena shortly after
the final round begins and an intense
battle ensues between the two contenders
Chang delivers a forceful kick
propelling Dre off the stage which
causes him to lose the first point
however he quickly turns things around
by defeating Chang and earning two
points in a row seeing this masterly
orders Chang to Target Dre's injured leg
heeding the instruction he lands a
powerful kick on Dre's injured leg
leaving him in excruciating pain now
that they are at a draw anyone securing
another point will become the winner
despite the pain Dre somehow manages to
get up and uses the snake stance he saw
at the temple earlier he successfully
manipulates Chang's movement and catches
him with an overhead kick to the Head
securing the final point and ultimately
defeating him with this Dre not only
wins the tournament but also earns the
respect of his opponents Chang
graciously presents the trophy to him
acknowledging his victory following this
all the fighting dragon students bowed
down to Mr Han accepting him as their
new master while a defeated Lee watches
on subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching